just boy get started with the video
today to want to mention another channel
I host called mega-projects there's a
channel all about mankind's greatest
achievements where I take a deep look at
incredible buildings project structures
and more whether it's the world's most
impressive skyscrapers the International
Space Station or Chernobyl's new
sarcophagus I cover it all new videos
come out a couple of times a week on
mega projects so if you think it could
be for you please do head on over and
subscribe there is a link below and
let's get into it
I am Darius the Great King of Kings king
of countries containing all kinds of men
King in this great earth far and wide by
the favour of her aura Mazda these are
the countries which I seized outside of
Persia I ruled over them they bought
tribute to me they did what was said to
them by me they held my law firm Lee
Media alarm Parthia area Bactria sogdia
taurus mir draggy anna
eric Hosea certain idea Gandhara India
the Hamad ring King Syrians the
Scythians with pointed caps Babylonia
Assyria Arabia Egypt Armenia Cappadocia
Lydia the Greeks the Scythians across
the sea Thrace the Sun Hat wearing
Greeks the Libyans the Nubians the men
of Makkah and the carians those are the
words of Darius the great that are
inscribed on his tomb he might have been
a true Achaemenid who saved Persia from
an impostor or he might have been a
usurper who carefully constructed a
narrative to portray himself as the
rightful ruler either way he became the
most powerful King in the history of
Persia the many lands under his domain
not only represented the Achaemenid
Empire at its largest extent but up
until that point the largest empire the
world had ever seen
[Music]
while information regarding Darius's
early life is spotty at best we know
that he was born circa 550 BC the oldest
son of his TAS best and Roda goon his
father was powerful man serving as a
satrap of Bactria satrapies were
semi-autonomous regions that king cyrus
the great employed in order to maintain
control over his vast arc eminent empire
therefore the duties and powers of a
satrap were similar to those of a
governor one of the main sources for the
lineage of darius is the b histone
inscription a large rock relief carved
straight into the mountains during his
reign in it the persian emperor traces
his roots all the way back to our hema
knees the legendary ancestor of all the
our eminent kings Darius was the son of
a stabbed sir son of our sames son of RA
omnis son of tastes best suit supposedly
was the son of our chemin EES taste this
was also the father of Cyrus the first
from whom the main lineage of Persian
kings was established that was the point
where the family tree splintered into
two branches and it wasn't until Darius
became King and married into the family
of Cyrus the Great that the two separate
lines were reunited once again or as the
inscription says eight of my dynasty
were kings before me I am the ninth nine
in succession in two lines we have been
Kings
at least that is what Darius wanted
everyone to believe there are still
lingering doubt surrounding the veracity
of his lineage some scholars think that
all of this was simply propaganda on
behalf of Darius to establish himself as
a blood relative of the previous kings
and therefore the rightful ruler of
Persia he took the throne by force so it
wouldn't have been surprising for
someone else to come forward and
challenge his claim there are a few
inconsistencies such as there being
almost no mention of our chemin ease
before Darius's reign propaganda or
truth
Darius's strategy paid off besides
commissioning Z the histone inscription
he also married not one not two but
three of Cyrus's female family members
two daughters named a toaster an artist
owned and a granddaughter and
named Pommies Darius's rise to the
throne of Persia is presented to us in
detail by good old Herodotus so expect a
fair that of myth and hearsay here after
the death of Cyrus the greatest son can
be seized ii became the new king in 530
BC he reigns for eight years time during
which he had several conquests in Africa
and helped expand his father's Empire he
died from a battle wound and 522 BC and
since yet no sons his heir was his
younger brother Bardia also called
murders by the greeks according to the
behistun inscription again the man who
took the throne was not bhadiya at all
but rather a man named gal marta who was
a Mayon a priest of Zoroastrianism this
claim was also supported by Herodotus
who said that can be seized had his real
brother killed in secret only a few
people knew of this treachery among
these being one of Cambay sees as
stewards named patters Isis who had a
brother named GAO mater who looked a lot
like Bardia when the king left to fight
in syria the two million siblings
orchestrated the plot to take the throne
with GAO mater posing as Bardia by the
time word of the conspiracy reached
Campisi's he was already far away on a
military campaign he began making his
return back to Persia but he perished on
the way and thus Bardia or Hamato
whoever he was became the new king he
was a popular King - although he only
reigns for a few months he won over the
people in his empire by decreeing that
all nations under his Dominion would be
exempted from tribute and military
service for three years the first to
suspect that the man sitting on the
throne was an impostor was a nobleman
named attains he had his suspicions
confirmed by his daughter who was one of
the Kings wives attains had her check to
see if her husband had is because the
Megane known as Gautama had previously
had his ears cut off as punishment she
wrote to him that the king did not in
fact have ears thus confirming to
obtains that this new ruler was an
impersonator he shared his findings with
a few other nobles who also had their
own suspicions they brought other
trustworthy men into their confidence
among them dari
they were seven men in total and they
pledged to overthrow the Asura the plan
was rather simple gain entry to the
Kings private chambers and slay him they
knew that the palace guards were
unlikely to stop them from gaining
access due to their high standing and
they were right they managed to enter
the royal court without much effort
before being approached by the eunuchs
who carried messages to the king at that
point that seven Nobles pulled out
daggers and started stabbing them
afterwards making their way into the
King's chambers they were fortunate both
maeín brothers were inside however they
had heard the screams of the eunuchs and
had time to arm themselves two of the
noblemen were injured during the fight
but they still managed to kill and
decapitate the service afterwards they
took to the streets shouting about what
they did showing off the heads and
rallying other Persians to their cause
indeed many others took up arms and
began killing all the Meggy and priests
that they encountered Herodotus notes
that this day later became an important
festival for the Persians known as the
massacre of the megan's
now that the usurpers have been dealt
with there was a new question that
needed to be answered who would rule
Persia obviously one of the seven would
gain kingship but which one attains
ruled himself out as he had no desire to
lead the rest abated and they decided on
what they believed to be a fair method
of selecting the new monarch they would
all travel outside the city and mount
their horses the winner would be the one
whose horse first made at sunrise
whether or not this was a just method
proved to be irrelevant because Darius
decided to cheat he walked up to his
horse groom named a Bars and told him to
come up with a trick so that his horse
would neigh on commands a Beres did as
instructed and devised one of two
schemes depending on the source both
involving a mare that caught the eye of
Darius as horse in one version the groom
simply brought the two horses together
at a meeting place the night before he
allowed them to mate and the next day
when the horse went back there
he became reminded of the good times and
made the other version of the story is a
bit more disgusting but probably also
more reliable according to ABARES he
rubs the mez genitals with his bare
hands
then when he wanted to make the male
horse neigh he simply brought his hand
up to the animals nose and let him sniff
it
whatever method was employed it worked
and Darius as horse was the first
at sunrise the other nobleman did not
catch on and pledged their allegiance to
Darius the new King of Kings ruler of
the our cabinet Empire
[Music]
Darrius may have haves the support of
the other major nobles of persia but
that did not mean that the general
population was as willing to embrace him
remember the king who came before him
just promised them all three years
without tribute not only to darius
rescind their promise but he made the
tributes Harsha Herodotus mentions that
the two previous our cabinet Kings Cyrus
and kam by seized both took their
tributes in the form of gifts each
satrapy giving how much they thought
appropriate darius established a fixed
annual tribute for each of his twenty
satrapies in his empire to be paid in
either gold or silver that's why they
called Cyrus the father because he was
merciful and cared for their well-being
cam by seize the master because he was
harsh and arrogance and Darius the
huckster because he always sought to
make a profit
out of everything unsurprisingly many of
the people of the arc eminent empire
rebelled against Darius fortunately for
him though he did have the Persian army
behind him and he was able to deal with
these results in the first couple of
years of his rule again it's the the
Heston inscription that provides us with
detail as Darius also used it to brag
about all the accomplishments that he
had during his reign he mentions nine
lion Kings from different parts of the
Empire who all rose against him and were
defeated of all the rebellions the one
in Babylon proved to be the most
troublesome a man identified in the
Piston relief as Nidan Dubiel gains the
kingship of the satrapy and proclaimed
himself to be nebuchadnezzar the third
son of nabo notice the last king of the
neo-babylonian empire darius took the
persian army and marched on babylon that
found a city with a strong army and
tough defenses that would not yield so
easily seemingly the argumented emperor
risked losing the war were it not for an
extreme plan devised by a general named
zhu Pyrus supply refers the son of
megabases one of the seven noblemen one
day he walked into Darius's camp with
his nose and ears cut off when the king
asked him who had done such a thing
sipar is replied that he did it to
himself his plan was to pretend to be a
deserter in exile and infiltrate the
Babylonians it worked
Pyrus was after all a high-ranking
officer so his knowledge would have been
valuable to the Babylonians who had no
that his mutilations would player signs
that he had fallen out of favor words
arias they accepted him and gave him an
army and supply hrus even gained a few
victories against the Persian forces to
help convince them that he was on their
side once he completely fooled the
Babylonians he opens the gates to the
city and the Persian army rushed in and
crushed the rebels for his sacrifice
Darius made soup iris satrap of Babylon
and gave him one of his sister's
marriage and other notable events from
that time was the death of inter
Franny's one of the seven nobles by the
order of Darius himself before they all
pledged their loyalty to one of their
own they made a pact specifying that the
other six would be able to visit the
royal court whenever they pleased
unannounced except for when the king was
in his bedroom with one of his wives one
afternoon in chief Enys did just that
but was sent away by two officers
because the King was indisposed angered
by this refusal enter Franny's pulled
out his scimitar and punished the two
men by cutting off their ears and noses
when Darius heard of this he began
fearing that interfer knees might be
plotting against him he had into
Franny's and all the men of his
household imprisoned with the intention
of executing them the no woman's wife
came to the court and wept and lamented
and pleaded with Darius who eventually
allowed her to select one family member
whose life he would spare surprisingly
she did not choose into Franny's or any
of her children but rather her brother
reasoning that she could get another
husband she could have more children but
she could not have another sibling
because her parents were dead
Darius agreed with our reasoning so the
brother was saved while intra Franny's
and his boys were put to death
[Music]
the military victories were what brought
darius renown but he also applied new
policies to improve the internal
structure of his empire we already
mentioned that he established new
satrapies and instituted a more
well-defined
taxing system but he also introduced
coins which became the monetary standard
in Persia they were called Derek and sig
loss the former being golden that
Blatter silver up into the last points
the Empire still used the coins they had
adopted from the Lydians under King
Croesus Darius also developed a network
of roads called the Royal Road to
facilitate faster travel and
communication throughout the arc eminent
empire in addition to the roadways this
ancient highway also had numerous
caravansaries which were outposts on the
side of the road where travelers could
eat sleep and change horses in the case
of couriers they could also pass on
their cargo to someone else who would
finish their journey while they rested
and waited for another courier to come
along with a new package moreover those
who were travelling on behalf of the
Persian governments like couriers and
inspectors were granted a form of
passport which entitled them to food
rations Herodotus also had high praise
for this innovation saying that there is
nothing in the world which travels
faster than the Persian couriers he also
said that they are stopped neither by
snow nor rain nor heat nor darkness from
accomplishing their appointed course
with all speed and a few thousand years
later this became the unofficial motto
of the United States Postal Service to
improve stability in his empire Darius
borrowed a page out of the book of Cyrus
and allowed religious freedom to the
conquered kingdoms and the tribes under
its domain
even though Zoroastrianism was the state
religion and in multiple inscriptions
Darius praised Ahura Mazda the supreme
deity of this religion he did not
persecute those who held different
religious beliefs and occasionally even
took part in some of their rites
Darius was also a prolific builder his
crowning achievement was the city which
he founded which she then turned into
the new capital of his empire
Persepolis inside the city there was the
palace complex which included a grand
construction known as the app Adana it
was an audience hall where Darius
received his most esteemed guests who
came to bring tribute to him the city of
Susa though it had been settled
thousands of years prior also became one
of the shining beacons of the pole
under Darius who built another Palace
complex there and used it as the second
residence dealing with rebellions was a
necessary step when taking the throne by
force and ruling a large territory but
what made Darius go down in history
where the conquests he made in order to
add to the ark emanate Empire his first
acquisition of note was the Indus Valley
region in the Indian subcontinent
sometime around 518 BC this was a
military campaign initially started by
Cyrus who made some minor successful
incursions in the area and conquered
several tribes west of the Indus River
which he organized as the province of
Gandhara its exact status at that time
is relatively uncertain because Darius
took the credit for officially
establishing it as a Santa pea of the
empire in 518 he also continued further
into the region and conquered an
additional province identified as hadoo
SH its exact location is unknown but it
likely correspondent to parts of
modern-day Punjab and the central Indus
basin Darius's next major conflict
involved one of Cyrus's enemies the
Citians the original war went decidedly
against the Persians it was after all
Queens myris leader of a sine lien
nation called the massive gate I who
defeated and killed Cyrus in battle in
513 BC Darius took his army and marched
from Sousa first targeting Scythian
regions located in modern-day Eastern
Europe along the coast of the Black Sea
a particular mention here was manned
Rock Lee's of Samos the chief builder
whom Darius commissioned to construct
him a bridge of boats so that his army
may cross the bosphorous and Dardanelles
straits and reach Europe Darius was
ready for battle
however the Syrians were not very
interested in giving him one they were
nomads and most of the lands they held
consisted of the barren Eurasian steppe
so they saw little sense in fighting and
dying to protect it instead the Syrian
King eyed and thyrsus
enacted a scorched earth policy he got
his best riders to engage and then run
away from the Persian army thus leading
them on a chase while the rest of his
forces made sure that the enemy found no
food or water on their course the
Citians also asked their allies for help
but most of them refused so in return
Ian's army began travelling without
permission through their lands towing
the Persians after them the goal here
was to force their now former allies to
either flee or fight this strategy
proved incredibly frustrating to Darius
at one point he sent a message to the
Scythian King demanding that he either
stand and fight or surrender and paid
tribute I'd and thyrsus refused giving
the reason we mentioned before they had
no towns or planted lands and therefore
had no fears that one would be taken or
the other wasted he did mention that
there was one thing the Syrians would
fight to protect the graves of their
ancestors if Darius desired battle he
should find them and try to destroy them
and then the Citians would attack that
being said the Citians did become more
aggressive and started launching -
skirmishes on the unsuspecting Persians
and preying on small scouting parties
Darius Sicilian campaign ended not with
a bang but with a whimper eventually the
ark eminent Emperor realized that it
just wasn't worth it to keep pursuing
the Citians forever continuously losing
soldiers to sickness starvation and the
occasional skirmish he opted to take a
small victory in the end he gained some
territory worthless or not in the
inscription on his tomb did mention
multiple Syrian people as among the ones
who brought in tribute he also destroyed
most of their alliances so the nomadic
nation lost some of its power and
prestige
[Music]
for the next decade or so Darius was
concerned with internal matters if
anything of note did happen we don't
know about it because there was a
thirteen year period with little to no
chronological evidence presumably the EM
bar was safe which allowed Darius to
focus on construction projects and other
activities to develop his empire there
were still minor confrontations along
side the edges of the Empire to
strengthen the borders but these were
handled by his generals
it wasn't until 499 BC the new crisis
arose with the Ionian revolt Ionia was a
region that corresponds to the western
coast of modern-day Anatolia which was
then occupied by Greek city-states
they'd originally been conquered by
Cyrus and now they decided all that had
enough
in fact the revolt was mainly incited by
one man named aristoi chorus he was the
tyrants of the Ionian city of Miletus
which in decades passed before being
conquered was considered perhaps the
wealthiest of all Greek cities in 499 BC
he tried to capture an island city-state
called Naxos he failed completely and
then started fearing that he would be
removed as leader of millet us therefore
Aristagoras felt that the only way to
stay in power was to rebel against the
persians
thursty managed to gain the support of
the people of millet us afterwards he
was joined by the other Ionian cities
after he had banished or killed their
tyrants this was starting to look like a
half-decent army but to ensure success
aristoi chorus still needed allies from
among the strongest greek factions when
it came to matters of war the first
choice was obvious eres de Goris went to
sparta to seek an alliance but he was
turned down by King Cleomenes the first
he felt that he couldn't spare his army
at the time afterwards aris decorous
went to Athens who did agree to fight
alongside the Ionian cities as did the
city of Eritrea in 498 BC a large force
of Greek soldiers mainly Athenians
marched on Sardis the former capital of
the kingdom of Lydia and one of the most
important cities of the arc aminal
Empire they burns the city and when word
of this reached Darius
he swore vengeance on them and
instructed a servant to tell him three
times each night at dinner
remember the Athenians after sardis the
Greeks went to a thesis but by then the
Persian army had had time to catch up to
them the two sides met in battle and the
Persians won the Athenians seeing that
the Persians were perhaps not the easy
pushovers that Aristagoras promised they
went back home leaving the revolting
Greeks to fend for themselves as far as
eros decorous was concerned he didn't
even fight at Sardis choosing instead to
remain in militants Herodotus who
described him as a man of new high
courage said that when the tide started
turning eros decorous took his army and
fled to Thrace but was killed by the
Thracians in combat
even without athenian support the Ionian
cities performed better than expected it
took six years for Darius to get all the
region's back under his control
afterwards it was time to remember the
athenians up until bad points the
Persians left the mainland Greek cities
alone but now Darius had a promise to
keep in 492 BC he launched the first
Persian invasion of Greece however he
did not lead the troops leaving that
task to his son-in-law
Mardonius he had some victories against
Macedonia and Eritrea but was ultimately
defeated in 490 BC at the Battle of
Marathon this is the battle that spawns
the famous legend of Phi deputies the
soldier who ran all the way from
Marathon to Athens to inform them of
their victory and then promptly died of
exhaustion
thus inspiring the modern marathon race
Darius was not prepared to accept defeat
instead he began raising another army
but was delayed by a revolt in Egypt he
fell ill and died in late 486 BC
approximately 64 years old his ambition
of punishing the Greeks was taken up by
his son and successor Xerxes who would
go on to launch a new invasion and fight
the Greeks including 300 very determined
Spartans but well that's a story for
another day
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit that like button if
you did also please do check out that
channel I mentioned at the beginning
mega projects which I'm going to link to
below and thank you for watching
[Music]